one last question from Yasha Bonta Yasha
Vantaa who says hey dr. Tyson I'm from
India
please will you run for president India
what something I'm pretty sure he means
here but that'd be pretty funny it's
just like will you run for president of
India is that a he or she yeah I don't
know
Chalmers name Yasha Vantaa Yasha bonza I
said I'm sorry I think you're female I
don't know I don't know okay but so I
know I actually on my website I have I
was asked why didn't I was asked by the
New York Times back when Congress was at
an impasse and they said let's ask
people who are not politicians if they
have solutions to this clearly the
politicians don't okay so they asked
like a musician and I'm like the
scientist they asked and I and so the
question is what would you do if you
were president and my answer was and is
and still is posted on my website not my
Facebook page I actually have a website
that's a hole fashioned I am that's it
what if I were president this is what
things would be and in there it says if
our president I would not be president I
have I don't have interest in leading
people right my interest as an educator
and especially as a scientist is
educating people right so that they can
make as an informed decision as they can
when they elect who they want to
represent them nice you just went around
swapping leaders back and forth you
haven't solved the electorate problem
Wow okay so the real problem with
America is we are too dumb the pit good
leader no no no no no let me say it
differently okay
the problem is if we have this if we
have dysfunctional politicians right
it's because we have a dysfunctional
electorate right the electorate puts
them in office hmm and if you say I hate
this guy better then vote him out right
hey you vote for these people in a
democracy in India the world's largest
democracy all right
yes we can control this stuff it's not
some King brought down from the ages
where you can't get rid of them and
the old days the only way they got rid
of him was how off with your head off
with your head okay
so so so I'm just saying I would rather
I would rather disseminate knowledge
wisdom and insight to all who I can so
that when they make their political
decision whoever they vote for it has
informed the decision as they possibly
can make Wow
that is good good stuff if you like this
please remember everything that we do
can be found commercial free plus
exclusive original content all on
Startalk all-access calm